to the dream scenario is I get taxed
[ __ ] that that's her dream scenario
because again rather than donating
through philanthropy uh she believes
which replicates power dynamics that
have created systemic inequalities in
the first place I think she's a [ __ ]
[Music]
so you actually sent over this in our
text thread the other day yeah um there
was this woman who is set to inherit
millions of dollars and wants to give
away 90 of her wealth oh it's 90 I
thought it was everything it was
billions right uh it's for her what
she's gonna receive is millions because
of she's part of uh it's her grandmother
uh who actually just passed away over a
month ago and she learned
oh no that was actually in 2020 wow
interesting uh as early in 2020 uh she
learned from an accountant that she
would inherit millions of Euros
following the death of her grandmother
who passed away the month prior
um her last name engelhorn that family
has amassed a multi-billion dollar
Fortune which began with Frederick
engelhorn who founded BASF one of the
world's largest chemical companies about
150 years ago in Germany
the headline that I saw that was so
funny is it was like
um she's heiress is annoyed that she's
gonna she's she's so annoyed she's gonna
inherit this money and she wants it
taxed away
a funny way to say it but though the
spin that I'm getting from this article
is a lot more philanthropic in a
different way right
um there's a kind of like a disdain for
non-profits she's so she obviously wants
to donate her wealth but there's kind of
this oh because it'll just go yeah like
it's the same uh I guess the the way she
describes it is there's the same
systemic issues in like modern society
and stuff like that those systemic
things are present in like non-profit
organizations and Charities whereas if
she gets taxed on this money and and the
wealth are just tax more that kind of
initiative that that money will at least
go into the system that benefits like
the larger group or it just sucked away
too yeah she doesn't think that the same
issues are in the government yeah it
gets sucked away both ways dude but
maybe it's different in Germany maybe
like it's not like here like they trust
their government maybe they're really
efficient maybe because I mean when you
go to you
a lot of places in Europe don't look all
[ __ ] up like here like it's like it's
like LA right it's one of the most
prosperous cities in the world but it
looks like
it looks post-apocalyptic yeah for sure
right yeah but then like I'm pretty sure
Europeans come to LA and they're just
like what the [ __ ] is this time dude
yeah and then you're they're like
walking down the street and they get
like robbed and [ __ ] like it's like
right man it's so different from when I
walked around you know like London or
Amsterdam or whatever aside from all the
beautiful ladies that are in glasses I
was like what's going on like why is the
street so clean and so different like
I was like is this is this yeah I'm like
why is there no trash and people
sleeping all over the floor like what
kind of city is this it's not a real
City that's true when you think of La as
like generating that much money and then
you look at it you're like that place is
the one generating that much yeah in New
York and all that he came to LA and he
posted a really cool documentary story I
was like look how many public bathrooms
there are Corner
yeah la generates more money than a lot
of European cities but for some reason
we can't be efficient and clean and like
our bus system sucks like it's always an
hour late our entire public transport
system sucks yeah and it's not safe dude
like everything just sucks I used to
ride that [ __ ] as a kid and then they'll
always be like a homeless man [ __ ]
pooping on themselves in the bus you
know a fight breaking out and [ __ ] like
one of my buddies is a bus driver for LA
and he says
after about noon the only people that
ride my bus are all homeless people that
talk to themselves that's it damn most
scariest yeah and he's just he that's
what he says he's like I'm [ __ ]
really scared and he says they have like
a shortage of bus drivers because
everybody's scared yeah nobody wants to
ride the bus nobody wants to drive the
bus I like the idea of the bus being
filled with homeless people but they're
really just talking to each other
crazy asses that happened to my my buddy
he's a skid row dentist which is
hilarious by itself oh that sounds scary
as [ __ ] yeah so like sounds like a good
guy he put a photo in our group chat of
some like uh homeless guy smeared his
[ __ ] all over the front doors
and then um the clinic of the clinic of
the actual like dentist office and then
he was like it's kind of sad because uh
all we do is free dentistry for homeless
people will be unhappy with something we
did
they're not in the same world yeah
don't tell them not to take it
personally yeah he's doing good work no
he doesn't he's just like it sucks
because like because half the time
you're getting your hand bit
when you're working on them
yeah he's like it's the worst thing is
that a joke no it's not a joke that's
really I love this Rich inheritance
story turning into a satire on L.A just
dunking on L.A I was thinking about this
the other day too because there we go
um I saw um it's not homeless related
but I saw this video uh remember Adam
ruins everything yeah so he has a
Conover yeah he has a YouTube channel
now and then he was talking about the
Patagonia billionaire giving away his
stuff and he was kind of like saying how
yeah he's not really giving it away
because he created this other charity
that he's still controlling Patagonia
he's giving it to this thing and in the
way he's maneuvering it he still
benefits right and then and he goes he
should pay his fair share in taxes and I
was thinking about that word fair share
and taxes and how billionaires should
give taxes to the government and this
and then just me being a small business
owner and then also seeing corruption in
the the city I was like I can understand
why
entrepreneurs and Millionaires and
billionaires don't want to give their
money to the government anymore because
once you see that the people that take
your money in taxes mismanage it
severely then you're like I'd rather
create my own you know organization and
give that way and hire the right people
that I trust and I was like no matter
what like there's corruption and Shady
people in private and public there's no
like honorable group so then
I'm like which one is the right one like
because everyone does have this disdain
for like government billionaires all
this stuff right but it's like maybe we
should not look at it in a way where you
blanket it as all government is corrupt
or all billionaires are [ __ ] up or
like you probably want to look at it
individually for every single
organization and say does this group do
it the right way or the wrong way yeah
yeah I don't know it sucks to not have a
choice when you look at like the
homelessness Coalition and how much
they've been mismanaging it for [ __ ]
decades and it's like oh well there's no
alternative like there's no oh you want
to donate to this Coalition or that one
or this one it's like it goes to the
government goes to them and they
constantly balloon the budget so it's
like what do you do have you heard of
the um like
I forgot the well term it's more like a
lot of government agencies from schools
to like military or whatever right uh if
you don't spend the budget then you
don't get the same amount next year and
it's almost like how production
companies work right so then a lot of
there's a lot of waste that goes on in
that kind of way of funding
um whether it's in film or whether it's
in a school because like let's say you
have a high school and you have to spend
the budget and you actually did well and
you have excess because you know you
balance your books well now you just
have to spend the rest of it or else
next year they go oh you don't really
need that much money so we're gonna
deplete that so what they'll do is
they'll just throw away all the tables
and chairs and just get new ones even
though if it's brand new and then
they're like it's it's just super
wasteful I got a buddy who works at a uh
at a college and um he's like a
maintenance guy and he says every year
he'll hit me up and take photos closed
captioning
not
available
hey it's
you by the way let's go baby they need
to donate that [ __ ] to Goodwill dude a
new bunk bed dude I'll get a U-Haul bro
yeah
you know how it gets to a point where
it's too expensive to throw certain
things away in a beneficial style yeah
like giving it to Goodwill you got to
pay somebody to [ __ ] manage that
transaction yeah so if you all just
shove it in a room then it's over that's
true you know and then these individual
uh maintenance guys just call their
homies and go hey you want some [ __ ]
lights you want some of this you know
and then I want some lights yeah the Sun
is up that's crazy how it works though
it's good don't you love our system it
makes so much sense yeah well in this
situation right she's
um she wants everything to be taxed away
she literally said the dream scenario is
I get taxed [ __ ] that that's her dream
scenario because again rather than
donating through philanthropy uh she
believes which replicates power dynamics
that have created systemic inequalities
in the first place I think she's a [ __ ]
people relate to people's individual
stories right like when you hear of
someone that like that's why we like to
watch all these Scorsese movies like
let's say the guy that robbed the bank
that got away like you you put yourself
anti-heroes exactly right so now you
have someone that came across all this
money and everyone in the world is
rooting for her what are you gonna do
with it and she goes I wish I didn't
have it I'm like you [ __ ] [ __ ]
awesome with it yeah yeah and then
Inspire us all rather than oh my life is
too I already had 20 million and this 1
million just made my 20 million even
more inconvenient
it sucks to see because somewhere out
there there's individuals that have all
the answers to do a really good thing
and all they needed is the money yeah
yeah that's the missing part of their
foreign
we shouldn't have all this money just
give it to the government
so they could spend it on Railways that
are never finished let's just keep
giving it away like Ballers Anonymous
yeah I have a problem 20 million dollars
I don't know what to do she has like an
opposite Check Into Cash business you
know like I hate this money and I don't
want it now
give it to the government give it to the
government so they could just buy more
missiles and blow people up come on she
has a non-profit do you have a problem
with too much money come to me we'll tax
it away for you so what does our company
do it sets fire to the bills it's a
group that is a movement to get other
millionaires to be taxed more oh my God
but she's an heiress right she's urging
government to take more of their money
but yeah yeah so that sucks I think
there's a difference between an error
let's look at that that sucks she didn't
build the company there's a difference
between heiress and entrepreneurs 100
and also I I was watching this
documentary about wealthy people in
Germany specifically this is the Germans
the uh uh what do you call it like
wealthy like um Legacy money not not
entrepreneurs right money yeah they're a
lot of them are low-key and they don't
like the attention and out there the
culture isn't like the US where we're
just like entrepreneurs are rock stars
and you can be shamelessly wealthy here
but out there a lot of the wealthy
people there's a lot of uh Nazi stains
because they made a [ __ ] ton of money
though some of the same families during
the that that era they still Rich so
they're trying to hide that that Nazi
stain maybe yeah I mean this is in
Germany and this is from her
grandfather's chemical Factory from 150
years ago like right behind the
chemicals bro chemicals you know which
was huge in World War one I'm not
touching you know what's really funny
though somewhere somewhere in this whole
thing she's at a board meeting and
there's some Billy Madison guy going no
no
like the guy in the suits like
13 year old
yeah [ __ ] volunteer my money dude
imagine that board meeting where then
she's got like 12 guys ensues and she's
like I've decided what I want to do with
it I think this just sounds really out
of touch from her Point huh what do you
think I think it's actually in touch in
her place that's true because like when
you didn't earn the money you don't have
the same relationship with it that's
what I mean but it's like just [ __ ]
do something dope it just do something
else instead of just giving it to the
government give it to JK maybe they just
believe in their guns BMW and they can
make an M9 M11
give it
maybe out there their government's a
little more trustworthy bring back the
chocolate taco or something
if I was rich that's what I'd do every
discontinued Bring It Back start a new
business dude come on just do anything
else if you want to be likable that's
what you do you bring back all the
childhood like fast food candies all the
stuff that went disconnect what a brown
noser huh I'm like a little brown does
it
[Music]
foreign
[Music]